[Música]
dicen los escandinavos que cuando tratas
de esconder un fantasma realmente lo
estás haciendo más grande y eso es un
poco las incertidumbres de pandemia que
tenemos los sanitarios o que nos hemos
ido enfrentando durante este tiempo yo
propongo la innovación disruptiva para
cambiar eso innovación siempre es
cambiar a mejor se supone las cosas que
hacemos habitualmente y disruptiva
quiere decir que es un salto cualitativo
y me pregunto a lo largo de la historia
ha habido las vacunas fueron un salto
disruptivo los antibióticos en el siglo
20 y el siglo 21 que tiene el siglo 21
debería tener lo que es la tecnología
digital la tecnología del móvil para el
usuario para el paciente
yo en mis carnes lo que lo acabamos de
ver
hemos tenido elementos disruptivos y una
vez trate de hacer un bloque en una
sociedad científica se me hizo un
consejo de guerra porque quería
comunicar a las nuevas generaciones de
otra forma y realmente tenemos un
problema los sanitarios no nos aburrimos
a nosotros mismos cuando comunicamos eso
es así tenemos una sociedad un poco
basada un poco lo he leído en el living
land no lo entiende no realmente no
y si os dijera que un niño con 13 años
es capaz de descifrar el código fuente
de un examen y ponerse en vez de un 10
para que el profesor no se dé cuenta eso
es una deberíamos premiar ese tipo de
inteligencia
y realmente yo me planteo qué ha pasado
durante la pandemia a nivel tecnológico
en nuestros sistemas de salud pues
realmente voy a contar lo que lo que
pasa es que yo no sé cuántos de vosotros
habéis tratado de llamar a un centro de
salud y qué respuesta habéis tenido el
caso es que en pleno confinamiento yo
llamaba mamá amazon en domingo y en 4
horas tenía un paquete en casa
y eso es una realidad es decir el 44 por
ciento de nuestros profesionales de
atención primaria no tienen herramientas
digitales para comunicarse con vosotros
salvo un teléfono si un centro de salud
tiene como 20.000 personas asignadas y
tres líneas de entrantes como
como van a [ __ ] teléfono es imposible
digamos qué
elaboramos diseños que no se adaptan
muchas veces a lo que
lo que el paciente necesita yo por
ejemplo colaboró en áfrica
estando en mauritania construyeron la
cooperación internacional un hospital
que las ventanas estaban a metro y medio
del suelo en un hospital que se ponía 50
grados porque el aire del desierto es
necesario que entre para refrescar lo
decir esa es nuestra idea de diseño y
tal y como lo planteamos
y es que somos en lo sanitario somos
expertos en hacer exámenes somos
expertos en engrosar currículum yo lo
llamo currículum porque hay que llevarlo
en un yo tengo mi mente llena de digamos
de reglas nemotécnicas de vez en cuando
me despierto sobresaltado digo tuve
cólera por el tifus de un pollo amarillo
con varices yo será para recordar que
voy a decir una cosa decir yo he
aprobado muchos exámenes con reglas
nemotécnicas pero eso no lo aplicado a
mi vida y probablemente el número uno
del mir no sea el médico que mejor
tratar los pacientes que no me voy
fijaros tengo la sensación de estar
convirtiéndome en un ser gris el 85% de
las personas están a disgusto en su
trabajo eso cuando lo tienen que hay un
15% que desgraciadamente no lo tienen
si os digo que el año pasado no hubo
prácticas a nivel sanitario que los
próximos sanitarios que vais a tener han
estudiado la teoría de cómo hacer
prácticas la frase esa de irte fuera al
extranjero huye cuando puedas investigar
en este país se premia
se premia la productividad basada en el
envejecimiento no la innovación los
trenes
es real y este dato confiada es
demoledor el 30% de mis compañeros de
familia han querido abandonar su
profesión este año
pero bueno yo no quiero ser negativo que
quiero hablar de cosas positivas que nos
ha traído la pandemia que son bastantes
aunque no lo creáis una de ellas este
año por ejemplo no ha habido gripe
gracias a la mascarilla que llamamos
todo ha habido tres casos cuando
habitualmente morían 3.000 personas
todos los años la gente aprendió a
lavarse las manos ha aparecido con puños
de discotecas de hace mil a mil mil años
no es que y eso es bueno y sobre todo
habido un reto que es el reto y esto es
lo que más me gusta la era molecular y
hasta aquí es decir el diagnóstico
que tenemos a la cabecera del paciente
ahora somos capaces de diagnosticar
hasta veintipico gérmenes en 15 minutos
y eso es esto ya está aquí eso tenemos
que aplicarlo y cuando hablo de
aplicación es una cosa que probablemente
el próximo año hay una revolución
tecnológica en la medicina pero eso
tiene que ser comunicado al paciente
a mí me gusta mucho el concepto de one
health health
es imposible entender la sanidad en este
momento si no trabajamos médicos
veterinarios y medioambiente
conjuntamente de nada sirve vacunar aquí
sino vacunamos allí los microorganismos
y eso lo hemos aprendido en esta
pandemia no entienden de fronteras ya mí
me gusta ser proactivo me gusta aportar
y en esta charla de aportar los cuatro
cosas que yo creo que necesita el
sistema sanitario caducó
ah me gusta también poner ejemplos de
directos y con una web que en tres clic
sal si es buena o mala que llega a donde
quieras pues lo voy a aplicar y eso que
entre cualquier persona este universo
hay cinco personas para conocer sobre
también me gusta cuatro ejemplos yo
quiero desburocratizar lo que hago el
80% de mi consulta es hacer papeles
justificantes pongo algún ejemplo hay
gente que pide cita para decirme que no
va a venir a la cita de los jueves
y eso es real digamos hay una serie de
herramientas tecnológicas y ese es el
segundo punto que tenemos que cambiar
que es la innovación tecnológica sabéis
en que va a emplear alemania el 90% de
los fondos de la pandemia en digitalizar
porque tenemos ahora mismo sistemas
obsoletos hemos hemos aprendido esta
pandemia que no estábamos preparados
tecnológicamente pero cómo te van a
[ __ ] el teléfono si es que es imposible
así es que no tenemos herramientas
el tercer punto comunicar yo creo que
los sanitarios tenemos que empezar a
comunicar de otra forma
dicen que la filosofía no existe sino
que existen los filósofos yo creo que la
ciencia no existe si no comunicamos esa
ciencia me gusta mucho los refranes
la belleza es interior el tamaño no
importa las redes sociales para la
ciencia no sirven como que no o sea no
puede ser que miguel bosé tenga dos
millones de seguidores en twitter
y que haya premios nobel que no tienen
ni siquiera cuenta yo creo que algo
estamos fallando en esto tenemos que
empezar a comunicar el cuarto punto y no
menos importante sabes cuáles las
personas
los recursos humanos ese es el valor de
cualquier empresa
sabemos que en muchas empresas hay más
jefes que indios y que son piramidales
me paso el día poniendo click para la
productividad
eso es un poco lo que hace realmente el
modelo cambiará cuando el valor de lo
que yo hago de ver mis 50 pacientes
cambien y la sociedad se dé cuenta que
el sistema se tiene que cambiar de
trabajo no es de regiones impuestas y
hablaba de cuando hablo de
digitalización no hablo de una
digitalización tipo una tele con markel
una marca de la distracción tiene que
ser inclusiva y el paciente tiene que
haber un salto generacional
pues la realidad es que mi hijo juan
tiene 2 años y no quiero que siga
algoritmos cerrados no quiero que le
guarden su libertad de expresión de
creatividad
probablemente la sociedad se enfrente en
los próximos años al mayor reto de su
historia tanto médicos farmacéuticos
arquitectos filósofos todos vosotros nos
vamos a enfrentar a un cambio
crítico después de esta pandemia y
realmente tendremos que hacer un pacto
generacional para que esto funcione
fijaros este dato en este momento no hay
ningún ser humano capaz de ganar al
ajedrez a deep blue una computadora
pueda decir otra cosa el futuro ya está
aquí lo que pasa es que está mal
repartido y en salida está muy mal
repartido
hace años de telecom decía lo de
connecting people
me encanta yo seré feliz si cuando
salgáis por esa puerta os haya
transmitido pues mi ilusión mi reto de
comunicar de transmitir de contactar con
todos vosotros yo me dedico a mis
pacientes y es lo que quiero
[Aplausos]